I'll forego embrace my despair and
welcome to another episode of Octodad
dadliest catch if we're gonna do
home sweet home today there we go
dr. dad drunk as hell and which fatherly
deeds are done in broad daylight Chapter
two
so yeah okay this is how you some guy
get out of bed no problem at all
God Depp who puts the alarm far away
anyway that is the Droid come on god
damn it Troy no how do I get rid of it I
just come on seriously
oh okay I got I know I got [ __ ] that's
what you [ __ ] get okay our next our
next duty okay we're gonna go to the
kitchen of course after that just has a
picture of himself laying around laying
down that's his heart and how oh that
picture wanted to go down for some
reason dr. dad good doesn't like it okay
no problem
sorry about that after that I there we
go that our son I'll just might get it
nice might be bad hey Dad son I mean I
just like hugging lamps don't worry
about it
hey I'm such there we go it's fine it's
fine I y'all doing okay just a little
sleepy that is a little up that is a
little sleepy don't worry about it
it's totally north told it talk on TV
don't break the TV girl up you broke the
TV that's not even a ticking okay we're
in the kitchen hey baby
wow you sound like a man that's okay hey
babe
are you doing mmm you want me to suit
you like that do you like when I you
like you like when I swirl around you
you like this [ __ ] you're into it you're
into kinky stuff
hmm oh yeah oh hello there girl are you
doing don't mind me I'm just a [ __ ]
octopus wants to feel nothing why do I
got to do to get this [ __ ] attention
hey girl
good good what's up oh don't mind me I'm
just normal stretching routine
okay make coffee seriously um okay it's
over here it's good she's not paying
attention to me I might add to column
it's burning oh okay okay we're fine how
it was it on nevermind it's poking
himself that's not gonna work after that
okay here we go yes
oh [ __ ] okay we need this thing okay
just I got ya okay disgust
okay ken can't go about can't go and do
your octave dad business okay now you're
just [ __ ] with me god dammit
are you serious okay I need I need a
better position that's right that's what
I thought
behind the back hell yeah okay and now
we just press oh why doesn't homework I
don't know how you made coffee you bros
drink coffee I'm glad it not heavy on
coffee
believe it or not okay don't don't run
it dad don't run away from me coffee bad
things happen to bad cop okay there we
go
I like that the game is that it's very
they did a good job balancing their
control cuz like most games uh
that are like kind of goofy with the
controls they're just impossible some
parts and it just makes you angry
okay get Stacie some milk okay fine
I don't even Haggar don't mind me I'm
just a go into them for the milk yes of
course
Oh tell us that many other one out of my
way Colston okay milk turn oh uh okay
that's not that's not mouth that's sana
bub toast I don't [ __ ] every go nuts
get them out that's a pineapple the
mouth that's a beer
oh wait that's okay
yes yes who's Stacey where the [ __ ] is
Stacey do you see these moves how can
you not realize I'm an octopus
I am literally in your face right now
and you don't okay this is our walk the
purses hug okay I need to stop [ __ ]
around if it's so much fun okay here we
go
oh yes hey girl I of the one you want
some milk
there you go you be a good girl what the
[ __ ] did she do she just jumps over
everything okay thanks dad I'll grow a
hundred okay can you do that alright now
I can drink my coffee finally oh [ __ ]
she's looking at me
I know you look you see these moves girl
you see these moves stick why don't one
hey girl don't mind me I'm just [ __ ]
my table yeah that's right you like that
don't be jealous woman it's normal
ask for an octopus - oh sorry sorry
sorry I didn't mean to hit you oh what's
up okay
I just just want my coffee just want I'm
not sorry about that just want my coffee
thanks girl
oh sorry I just a friendly slap how do I
drink it got it yeah yes yes number one
dad [ __ ] number one day number one
day girl uh okay what do I do now how
did you energize I need you to take care
of some things
oh geez there's a bunch of stuff today
burgers for lunch and you're gonna stare
at me this entire time
where I chase those greedy sons of
[ __ ]
I can't speak English oh I thought to
dig for sure calm your tits okay get
away
oh yeah just put that fish there not
that one okay and then but that [ __ ]
day yeah okay this is done who won
someone you want one hey girls
stop not being a [ __ ] I do not raise a
[ __ ] okay this this is out I am
grilling my genitals this is our
birthing okay now just get the burger
just get the burger that sounds like
similar to fapping dad okay I'm stuck
I'm stuck in the grill don't know oh I
am [ __ ] the grill okay here we go
nah I think I'm grilling it
there we go that one is done oh stop
being a little worse did not raise it
worse
okay well it's the last meet anyone
why not grill myself sometimes at the
same time I mean okay how do you know
what their big nevermind okay [ __ ]
ain't [ __ ] in they ain't saying thanks
dad it looks delicious
I know I made it my own a little leave
the garden what the hell sorry I'm okay
okay I don't know how to read a garland
I'm sorry I really what is a weed oh I
think it's when you take away their
grass okay thanks
thank you away why do I have to do all
this [ __ ] god dammit I'm an octopus
don't I shouldn't have go away there we
go
suck it you're coming with me Gandalf
that's right mind your friend okay here
we go hotshot ice pick top god damn it
this is not what I wanted at all
come on ah grab it there we go
okay okay hot cha hot cha cha cha
come on are you saying yeah chop
everywhere with it
goddamn you Oh nailed it fire axe just
touch it
totally how it works okay there we go
get them over from this mover from this
Oh get the mover from the shed I'm such
an idiot okay
oh this is not gonna be good
oh jeez why so many balls why there we
go I got it
move the lawn are you serious yeah it's
like move the lot
watch it learn Bruce you have so much to
learn from Octodad we all have yes yes
of course yeah seriously yes of course
how else would you do it what the hell
did I just do
I'm tryharding so hard just this is
gameplay this is real gameplay [ __ ] Call
of Duty boy moving oh [ __ ]
why is that suspicious activity come on
what sir you never seen a man movies
long before oh oh that's gotta hurt
don't you get your tentacles in there
there we go
what am I supposed to do now so many
[ __ ] to do Octodad is tired get get away
from me hang out the birdhouse more
summer tell me this is gonna be
difficult
I've got you now octopus so now oh well
it was noon
stop the chef how how ah damages you're
a murderer
god damn it oh oh ah man
the life of an octopus alright then that
was that this gave us a lot of fun i
hope you bros had fun playing with me I
just got a phone call
subscribe to come over today remember to
check out the link to off the dad if you
want to check out dude yourself you can
play the early version of it right now
for free actually so that's pretty cool
sounds both love you oh hell yeah
haha swag swag enjoy the clip
good best game ever wonder how I got my
[ __ ] you